ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
welt es ist wirklich schon mit hier
dürfen dementsprechend gar nicht lange
zeit verlieren und müssen direkt mit
unserem ziel für die heutige episode
starten denn guten morgen wir müssen
direkt in unserem ziel für die heutige
episode starten und dafür springt die
ich mal direkt hier runter zu unserem
kleinen bötchen denn wir müssen jetzt
weil du kannst auch auf dem festland
warten ich fahre jetzt erstmal hier
rüber zu unserer kleinen baum insel auf
der ich ja immer so ein bisschen das
holz fälle weil auf meiner insel die
bäume die möchte ich eigentlich
dabehalten von daher hier erstmal den
eichenbaum mitnehmen und davon brauchen
wir wirklich eine ganze menge denn in
der heutigen episode möchte ich etwas
bauen was mir die kommentare geschrieben
wurde und zwar mir geschrieben luca baut
auf dem baumhaus für deinen zauber tisch
für einen rauschenden ich mehr machen
kann mit meiner lohnen route die sache
ist dass ich die idee mit einem baumhaus
nicht geil finde weil ich glaube jeder
der dieses projekt hier seit dem beginn
an verfolgt weiß wie sehr ich bäume
liebe wenn man sich meine insel dahinten
anguckt sieht man auch das ist quasi der
baum als inseln dementsprechend werde
ich den plan mit dem baumhaus auf jeden
fall angehen in meinem fall allerdings
nicht für den zauber tisch weil dafür
habe ich bereits die zauberinsel und
auch nicht für den brauch stand weil da
wollte ich mir auch noch was cooles
überlegen sondern ich werde ich werde
das baumhaus als lagerungs system nutzen
und dort einfach eine menge kisten
reinstellen eine menge wasser einfach
weil ich halt merke dass in meinem
kleinen haus nicht genügend platz ist
und nicht genügend platz ist mein
häuschen hier platz einfach aus allen
nähten und da kommt
jetzt warum und dafür nehmen wir einfach
unsere rote blume cayman und packten die
in die werkbank da haben wir nämlich
roten farbstoffe ich habe auch gerade
schon meine eichenholz stämme zu
eichenholz gemacht da habe ich auch noch
ein bisschen was aus meiner kiste
genommen bevor ihr wieder irgendwer sagt
dass ich irgendwas schicken würde den
kommentar habe ich auch letztens gelesen
wo ich mir dachte pro verfolgen würde
das wusstest du dass ich das einfach
über ein buch gemacht hat und deswegen
nicht egal ich will mich von solchen
idioten nicht ablenken lassen und mit
nicht den spaß an diesem projekt nehmen
wollen aber ach das sind immer noch so
fischer ja kein fisch denkt sich jetzt
will ich mal eine oberfläche wo ich
nicht atmen kann die ich muss allerdings
noch mal kurz zu unserer bauminseln
überfahren und athletischer und im
inland habe ich mir eine schere für
gemachte denn ich benötige eine menge
blätter für so ein baumhaus wie kann ich
denn jetzt schon wieder bei 20 minuten
seien es ist so selbst feine minecraft
plötzlich sachen so richtig schnell
abbauen kann der neue axt habe ich auch
noch mit dabei dann kann ich mir das
noch eben mitnehmen und hier den rest
auch noch geben mitnehmen die ganzen
laubblätter hier vorn ich brauche
nämlich tatsächlich 26 laubblätter habe
mich da wieder ein bisschen inspirieren
lassen
bei einigen tutorials auf youtube das
baumhaus angeht ich werde auch keine
riesiges baumhaus bauen aber es wird auf
jeden fall nicht ganz geil glaube ich
und daher bleibt auf jeden fall bis zum
ende von der video daran und abonniert
bei den kanal
wenn ihr noch kein teil von lugo seite
[Musik]
ich habe gerade sieben minuten langen
die ganzen sachen zusammengesucht einen
kompletten minecraft hat es lange
gedauert das war überhaupt kein
richtiges deutsch gerade womit wir nun
allerdings erstmal anfangen ist das ja
alles so ein wenig zu erweitern denn das
baumhaus soll genau ich hier vorne
stehen das heißt den apparat brauchen
also erstmal hier das wasser zu bauen
und dann hier vorne die lava ich glaube
das war meine einzige lava die ich bilde
mir leichter die die haupt bettet man
einmal raus nehmen müssen
aber ich weiß nicht wofür man einfach
braucht also in jeder tipps habt
schreibt sehr gerne in die kommentare
wurden auch schon richtig viele tipps
fürs brauen unten in die kommentare
geschrieben
hier wurde mir auch gesagt ja luca mit
dem glas darüber dann können sie nicht
schlüpfen aber ihm gestützten die bei
mir überhaupt nicht also ich weiß nicht
was ich falsch mache aber die kommen
jetzt auch erstmal weg die komplette
ecke hier vorne soll eigentlich voll mit
erde werden weil ich schon immer mit
ihnen komisch fand dass der wand sich
dann irgendwie so ein bisschen hoch
gezogen hat und so dann solltest lieber
irgendwie so hier aufgebaut sein dass
sie alles ein bisschen er ist und die
kag lamas sind ja immer noch hier und
dann kleinen wir hier auch alles in
unserer erde aussieht jetzt gerade
natürlich ein bisschen doof aus und es
sieht doch eher so aus als hätte ihnen
hier irgendwie die schafe und schweine
die ich habe drauf gepackt allerdings
wird das natürlich nachher alles zu gras
und dem schmiedete sprach ich noch mal
ganz kurz hier rein denn wir nehmen uns
jetzt erstmal das eichenholz und werden
hier so ein baumhaus hinsetzen
dafür muss der brauchen wir allerdings
weg also das hier ist quasi so die
grundlage da gehen wir jetzt allerdings
mal so ein stückchen weiter hoch zack
zack zack zack und hier den seiten dann
auch noch mal ein bisschen hoch
beziehungsweise hier in dem baumhaus
drin geht einen stamm sehr weit nach
oben nämlich insgesamt sieben blöcke und
da kommen die leute dort kommen unsere
leitern dran und von dort aus erreichen
wir dann unsere baumhaus was dann auf
der höhe hier sein wird dass wir können
ein bisschen über die fichte ist
gewachsen hier vorne in die ecken kommen
jetzt erst mal einige blöcke die wir
nachher wieder wegnehmen werden also
lasst euch davon nicht irritieren
die stämme drauf und hier kommt auch
wieder erst mal eher dahin die wir auch
nachher wegnehmen und hier geht es dann
auch noch ein bisschen weiter dass sie
bildet nämlich alles so ein bisschen den
stamm ja doch ich doch mit einer menge
fantasie kann man sich da schon ein
bischen vorstand hier geht es jetzt auf
jeder seite noch mal drei blöcke in die
höhe zack zack zack und hier vorne auch
zack zack zack damit das ganze halt ein
bisschen stabiler und auch nach ein
bisschen was ausgibt ich hatte erst
überlegt so ein kleines bauernhaus zu
machen in einem baum dem wir neben
unserer denkmal für die verstorbene katz
und die crew haben nämlich nie in diesem
baum hier rein er ist ja auch ziemlich
groß geworden an der stelle aber erst
mal eine kurze schweige sekunden für den
tod unserer katze und der coup der kühl
wenn man der letzten folge sondern
komplett nassen grab errichtet danke da
auch noch mal vor enorm krasses feedback
bei der letzten episode das hat mich
wirklich extrem gefreut
viele haben das video einfach aus
prinzip gesetzlich weil ich die kühe
getötet habe das konnte ich natürlich
auch verstehen und ich habe es natürlich
auch so ein bisschen provoziert mit der
art wie ich das ganze im schnitt
umgesetzt habe mit der traurigen musik
und so weiter und so fort aber danke
danke danke vorher generelles feedback
zu dem projekt das kann ich nicht oft
genug sagen hier vorne
das bildet so ein bisschen den rhein
gang und da kommt jetzt auch eine
fichtenholz tür rein nämlich so sieht
nicht so schön aus sind generell schöner
wenn man in minecraft türen von innen
setzt man sieht von außen halt so aus
man hat so einen richtigen eingang
wissen wie ich
eine stunde aufnahmezeit ein neuer tag
es angebrochen und ich finde man kann
diese morgenstunden immer mal so ein
bisschen nutzen um wirklich sie sich zu
danken für unsere welt also klar logisch
ich habe das ja alles gibt um so aber es
ist ja schon crazy wie sich alles
entwickelt hat mit der zeit und da bin
ich auch extrem dankbar für die ganzen
tipps die immer in die kommentare
schreibt ohne euch wäre das projekt nur
sogar wenn ich sogar noch weniger hier
setzt sich noch so eine treppe dran und
da vorne dran kommt jetzt auch eine
fichtenholz stufe denn je die kommunen
hört die habe ich mich zum falsch
gesetzt sagt die vom dahin
und da kann man jetzt nämlich eine
laterne hinlänglich kommen generell noch
einige laternen dran aber ich liebe
laternen in minecraft und ich glaube das
merkt man wenn man sich mal eine
komplette web anschaut hier vorne würde
ich so zeuner hinsetzen mit fichtenholz
falltüren obendrauf das haben wir auch
bei meinem haus und ein bisschen gemacht
mit den falten immer hin und her sieht
eigentlich ganz schön aus und jetzt
bewegen wir uns tatsächlich zum ersten
mal so richtig nach oben und werden hier
ein bisschen bauen denn dafür nehme ich
die fichten holztreppen die ich habe und
platziere die ich hier an jeder seite
und dann bilden wir mit unseren
fichtenholz stufen so ein bisschen den
untergrund beziehungsweise den boden für
unser baumhaus ich weiß ich hatte früher
als kind mal so ein baumhaus also wir
haben das einmal probiert aber in
deutschland hast doch nicht so kranke
bäume okay was will ich erwarten alter
das ich im dschungel auf wachstum daten
baumhaus bauen wir hatten halt damals
sondern art höhle die wir uns gebaut
haben also das war auch eigentlich hatte
das mit einer höhle eher weniger zu tun
sondern mehr mit so einer kleinen coole
oder so und da war es bei uns auf jeden
fall so dass wir das so als unser baum
ausgesehen haben das hat halt nicht im
baumhaus zu tun so ich da wenn man
stellt sich sein baumhaus immer so vor
dass man dann über allem thront und über
ein kleines dorf gucken kann und so
weiter und so fort ist bei uns leider
nie so richtig der fall
wir hatten halt auch keinen richtigen
weiter wo ich herkomme also wieder fällt
klar es gibt extrem viele wälder aber
jetzt nicht irgendwie wo man alles so
unentdeckt hat und so weiter und so fort
wir waren immer im tierpark olderdissen
ich weiß nicht ob das jemandem was sagt
er vielleicht auch aus der ecke aus
westfalen lippe kommt aber da haben wir
uns so eine coole gebaut irgendwo und
das war immer ganz cool das war so unser
unser ort so ein bisschen
ich darf hier nicht so krass ablenken
lassen denn man muss sich jetzt hier vor
allem bei dem gras so ein bisschen das
ist laut lukas idiot es mit den
laubblättern hier setzt auf jeden fall
recht schwierig weil ich jetzt gucken
muss wo ich meinen balkon so ein
bisschen hin setzt also es wird kein
richtiger balkon
ich glaube ich bin einfach mal hier hin
dann haben wir nämlich hier ein kleiner
ausblick und in die richtung haben ja
schon von unserer hütten ausblick
deswegen mache ich jetzt einfach mal
nach hier und hier vorne auch noch mal
genau das gleiche
ich weiß wirklich nicht wie später
aussehen wird aber es soll dann quasi so
sein dass man hier hoch kommen dann hat
man hier quasi die ganzen sachen hier
vorne kommt dann zum beispiel das
bettchen hin und dann haben wir überall
so thrun und kisten stehen allerdings
müssen wir hier jetzt erstmal erde
blöcke hinsetzen die wir natürlich auch
selbstverständlich nachher wieder weg
machen werden
aber das wird unsere letzte die
vorletzte ebene an blättern auf jeden
fall sein sagt sack hier vorne noch hier
da und hier und hier
vielleicht hat man in der times gesehen
ich habe meine lagerfeuer unten mit der
spitzhacke abgebaut dass sie ganz
einfach daran weil wir sie so bekommen
und ich die dann hier wieder hinsetzen
kann und das finde ich eigentlich ganz
schön wenn man lagerfeuer so ein
bisschen als dach benutzt das haben wir
beim stall gemacht beim kuhstall
da habe ich auch ein paar lagerfeuer
weggenommen ich weiß nicht was man hier
sieht sonst kann ich mal ganz bisschen
laufen also hier vorne bei dem kuhstall
habe ich auf jeden fall ein paar
lagerfeuer weggenommen ich weiß nicht
warum das schaf das schild ich will dich
hier haben aber du beleidigst mich die
ganze zeit
man merkt auf jeden fall super wird bist
du auch wenn du dich darum guckt walter
kurze die schaufel nehmen und die
hieraus machen und hier vorne sollen
euro welche hin nämlich soundso hier
kommt kein sinn denn hier nehme ich
jetzt wieder meine blätter und packe die
hierhin denn das wird jetzt die letzte
ebene an blättern die wir hin packen
werden
ich bin soll ihm ich habe auch schon
überlegt das wetter hat auch noch einen
höher zu setzen allerdings ist das ja
auch der sinn von einem baumhaus dass es
jetzt nicht so geräumig sein soll
das bettchen würde ich jetzt einfach mal
hierhin packen dann haben wir so ein
bisschen im planb und mit unseren
pflichten holztreppen da muss ich noch
mal ganz kurz raus kann ich das jetzt
einfach mal hier ganz kurz hinsetzen das
finde ich eigentlich auch ganz schön das
haben wir auch bei unserem haus ein
bisschen so gemacht bei dem dach und
dann stelle ich ja auch noch seine
treffe so hin hier vorne kommt natürlich
wieder das ding hinwollen das ist schon
schön kann man hier können wir
vielleicht auch noch was offen machen
dann muss ich mir überlegen aber hier
auf jeden fall das bettchen hier vorne
geht die sonne schon wieder unter ich
bin bei eineinhalb stunden allerdings
fällt mir grad auch wieder auf dass ich
ja eigentlich noch mal ach da habe ich
eine falsche gesetzt ich muss dir auf
jeden fall noch mal kurz hoch um nochmal
ich hier eine treppe draufzusetzen
nämlich so und hier soll dann eine
eichenholz feld führt daran die sollen
nämlich hier so hin und hier vorne noch
eine stufe mit einer laterne das soll
genauso sein wie unten zack und dann
gehe ich jetzt einfach mal hier um die
kurve und kann dann hier eine laterne
dransetzen
dann sieht es von unten
sieht so aus also hier kommen natürlich
auch laternen allerdings gehe ich jetzt
tatsächlich erst mal hoch und schlafe
unsere erste nacht im baumhaus dann
setze ich zwar meine wiedereinstiegs
punkt da sind jetzt unten links es ist
kein cheap an alle die mir das jetzt
wieder vorwerfen in den kommentaren und
jetzt können wir hier vorne den reichen
laut blog nochmal hinsetzen die erde
abbauen ich glaube aber dennoch dass ich
das bett hier weg nehmen werde und er
hierhin packen werde weil man liegt er
im bett und dann guckt man ja gerade aus
und da guckt man natürlich lieber da hin
wenn einem bett liegt weil das hab ich
gerade gesehen hat sich hier lag habe
ich hab da geguckt das war jetzt nicht
so unfassbar geil hier fehlt auf dem
blog so jetzt geht's eigentlich nur noch
als einrichten das können jetzt einmal
machen wie wir wollen ich hab mir
gedacht dass ich hier so eine werkbank
hinsetze macht zwar keinen sinn weil es
endlich mehr lagerraum werden soll aber
wenn ich mal was kräften muss uns zu
lagern dann war es eigentlich schon hier
vorne wollte ich ein fassl setzen und
auf das fast eine truhe drauf und
daneben eine fichtenholz treppe hier und
fichtenholz treffe da da können wir dann
auch einfach mal hier eine laterne drauf
stellen und hier vorne vielleicht einen
blumentopf mit mohn das finde ich auch
mal ganz cool so ein bisschen das alles
einrichten das schon süß
dann können wir hier was lagern und da
was lagern dann machen wir das genauso
hier vorne mit den treppen werden hier
allerdings keine laterne drauf setzen
sondern hier auch kisten und kästen hier
werde ich auch noch so eine treppe
hinsetzen das sieht auch eigentlich ganz
schön aus und hier vorne habe ich mir
gedacht könnte ich so ein räucherofen
packen und vielleicht eine schmiede
tisch und dann nehme ich noch mal die
fichtenholz falltür und platziere die so
kann ich doch 'ne kiste darauf stellen
oder ist sogar zu viel stauraum dem ich
mittlerweile haben ich weiß nicht ich
bin ich noch nicht so ganz happy können
wir das selber gerne und in die
kommentare schreiben wir das machen
würde die jetzt müssen wir uns
allerdings noch um die außenbeleuchtung
kümmern und dafür habe ich mir gedacht
hier einfach an die ecke noch mal einen
zaun runter mit einer laterne dran und
um die laterne drum an der seite laub
und das ganze auch noch mal auf der
anderen seite hier ich weiß nicht ob ich
das alles zu sehr
falls käme in meiner map mit
laternen und licht und so aber hier sind
einfach so viele monster das ist auf
jeden fall sinn ergibt ich glaube ich
mache da hinten sogar daran dafür muss
man allerdings erst noch eine kräfte
neben das tor auf ex auch schneller als
mein bart hier vorne
rom mit nimh und dann können wir uns da
raus auf jeden fall noch mal wieder ein
bisschen papier machen das papier können
dann wiederum tauschen mit den
villingern wodurch camerons bekommen
allerdings sind hier meine ganzen kiste
mittlerweile schon so gut wie voll
ich muss mich jetzt allerdings erst mal
darum kümmern dass ich meine reisen
nehme die habe ich hier vorne und die
packe ich jetzt hier einmal drumrum eine
fackel in die mitte und ich hab eine
laterne und diese letzte laterne habe
ich mir überlegt platzieren wir auf die
rückseite von dem baum die könne nicht
mehr generell mal anschauen
also wir werden den baum ja die meiste
zeit nur von vorne sehen aber von hinten
doch sieht schon geil aussieht schon
cool aus also hier kommt natürlich noch
bei mir und so weiter und so fort daten
dann sieht das noch mal ein bisschen
besser aus allerdings wollte ich den
hier erzähle ich das an der falltür
nicht ob das wirklich so neuhaus ich
packte lieber einen davor und dann hier
mit der laterne und dann nehmen wir
wieder das laub und packen das einfach
mal auch hier so rum an den seiten so
ein bisschen dass das auch so verbucht
aussieht normalerweise hätte ich hier ja
dann die laternen hin gemacht aber auf
der rückseite ist eigentlich scheißegal
ob ich das so ich glaube ich mache sogar
hier auch noch ein bisschen was hin so
und so könnte das hier auch nochmal so
ein bisschen vertreter aus das kann mir
auch ein ich mal ein bisschen runter
wachsen lassen sieht es vielleicht noch
mal ein bisschen besser aus hier auch
nochmal so ein bisschen und dann hängt
das irgendwie hier nicht aber vielleicht
hier doch nochmal so ein ticken weiter
runter und hier vorne machen wir das
auch und hier an der seite auch dann
sieht man mal so ein bisschen verbuchte
aus hier das ich weiß ich bin nicht
zufrieden damit was haben sollte dann
schreibt mir gerne in die kommentare ich
finde es eigentlich ganz geil dafür dass
es jetzt ein startup baumhaus ist also
ich meine ich bin ja nicht jetzt
irgendwie einem dschungel wo ich eh
schon fette bäume habe sondern muss mit
dem arbeiten was mir gegeben wird in
dieser welt würde allerdings sagen dass
ich noch mal ganz schnell nebenbei hole
ich hoffe dass ich überhaupt noch
knochen habe oben weil er hier schon
alles müssen verwundert es nicht dass
bei williams käme wie sonst was
allerdings haben wir vier knochen und 17
bei mir haben wir noch okay das reicht
auf jeden fall deutlich aus ich hätte
auch noch mal kurz ein bisschen
verrottetes fleisch mitnehmen das kann
ich dann meine ist es an meinem hund
verfüttern ich glaube er mochte dass ich
mich gerade falsch wenn du hast du bock
auf ein bisschen fleisch wir nehmen das
spiel und spammen dass sich einfach mal
so ein bisschen auf den boden damit dass
hier so ein bisschen verbuchte aussieht
hier vorne ist es noch nicht so ganz zu
groß geworden aber das wird dann auf
jeden fall bis zur nächsten folge der
fall sein
ich habe keine ahnung wann die
spiegeleier hier schlüpfen
schildkröteneier hier schlüpfen werden
allerdings sollte das auch nicht mehr
allzu lange dauern und dann haben wir
hier süße schildkröten doch das sieht
schon geil aus jetzt mit dem
verwachsenen hier so ein bisschen das
sieht schon cool dass ich könnte noch
mal eben ganz kurz meinen weg hier so
ein bisschen fertig machen dass er hier
so um die kurve geht sagt st und dann
sieht dass hier auch schon so ein
bisschen besser aus doch das ist sehr
geil ich freue mich ich bin zufrieden
was sagst du
perfekt dankeschön die auf jeden fall
für das kompliment wie gefällt euch das
beschreibt sie gerne und in die
kommentare ich finde sehr gut wir können
uns selbst das ganze nochmal hier beim
nacht anschauen
ich weiß ich was ich hier drin machen
soll ich glaub ich mache das auch so ein
bisschen verbucht hat es ist halt ein
baumhaus
es darf jetzt auch nicht so cool speak
lineal aussehen wenn man hier dann
allerdings hoch kommen sieht man schon
überall blätter hier sind eine menge
kisten hier hat man beleuchtung hier
vielleicht noch wasser könnte ich
vielleicht noch eine tour sogar
hinsetzen
ich glaube die nächste folge ich wollte
erfolge machen idiot ich habe mich extra
gesagt gesagt mir fragen in die
kommentare schreiben
das könnte jetzt auf jeden fall machen
freunde also in der nächsten folge wird
es definitiv der insel reparatur folge
ist jetzt ja auch noch meine kiste hin
dachte schon
also das ist ein richtiges lager
baumhaus hier da kann ich dir vielleicht
sogar auch wegnehmen
denn damit einen kleinen ausblick hier
vorne und das sieht ein bisschen schöner
ausfindig aber die sonne geht unter
meine lieben freunde und an der stelle
würde ich jetzt auch die heutigen
episode microsoft mit luca beenden wenn
es euch gefallen hat dann lassen einen
daumen hoch und ein video der abonniert
main kanal als noch bei der luxus seite
die nächste folge minecraft mit luca
übermorgen samstag nicht verpassen
wollte wir sehen uns
[Musik]